members of Congress are demanding to
know why FEMA chose a one-person company
to provide 30 million meals to hurricane
ravaged Puerto Rico in October the
agency awarded an the early one hundred
and fifty six million dollar contract to
Atlanta businesswoman Tiffany brown
she is the sole operator of Tribute
contracting as first reported in the new
york times she delivered fewer than
50,000 meals before the contract was
canceled tens of thousands of unused
meals now sit inside this storage locker
David beg no got a look inside he joins
us from Atlanta good morning David John
good morning here are the meals they're
small but this will make one big meal
for one person every day this is chicken
and rice it's better than the skittles
in Vienna sausage we saw in some
packages in Puerto Rico look you talked
about the congressional members they
have sent out a letter saying
essentially that FEMA is to blame for
selecting a woman who had no real
disaster experience prior to this my
biggest regret was that the people of
Puerto Rico did not get the food what
was your biggest mistake not asking for
more help on this project Tiffany brown
says she had the best of intentions when
she told FEMA she could send 30 million
meals to Puerto Rico even without any
experience in a large-scale disaster the
agency approved her bid in just three
days this would have been probably the
biggest thing you've ever done yes
absolutely for most people yes and you
pour the water in it her plan was to
outsource production of self-heating
meals to a large processing company in
Texas and a corporate caterer in Atlanta
who had just 11 employees did you really
think that 11 people were gonna do
millions of meals she told me she was
it's Paris with this work and as time
went on that she would be able to hire
additional people to scale up the first
50,000 meals arrived in Puerto Rico late
and separated from their heating bags
FEMA refused to distribute them and
rejected more than 75,000 additional
meals that were on the way Brown who
describes herself as a diva mogul author
and idealist on Twitter was paid two
hundred and fifty five thousand dollars
her company Tribute contracting
has had five prior government contracts
all terminated one agency even said she
was ineligible for any more bids until
January 2019 big day I love you renowned
chef Jose Andres who through his charity
has provided more than 3 million meals
to hurricane victims in Puerto Rico
responded to our story on Twitter saying
Tiffani Brown has nothing to do with the
larger problem the people at FEMA
awarding this contract should be fired
he tweeted we had a plan we had it
mapped out kendra robinson is that
atlanta caterer who says she's made
about seventy thousand meals that are
just sitting in storage so who's to
blame here bad management of fema it
can't be a small business that did
everything they could to be a part of
the solution tiffany brown says there's
one more big thing fema didn't want to
pay her upfront they wanted to pay her
down the road and that she says forced
her to find subcontractors who were
willing to take a risk and wait to be
paid later Norma's brown has been paid
two hundred and fifty five thousand
dollars so far but she's appealing to
FEMA for 70 million more Wow what what
does she want that seventy million for
she says she deserves it she'll never
get that 156 million but she thinks the
money that she spent out-of-pocket and
remember she's got to pay the
subcontractors so she's asking for
seventy million who knows if she'll ever
see it but she didn't deliver though
that's a very interesting question and
quite a bold request I have to say yeah
thank you David